sehr geehrte damen und herren
abschließend richtig nochmals meinen
dank an alle die zum gelingen dieses
einsatzes beigetragen haben
ich wünsche ihnen weiterhin viel erfolg
und soldatenglück getreu unserem motto
schützen und helfen dort wo andere nicht
mehr können
ein neutrales land das teilnimmt dass
sich bekennt dass die pflicht erfüllt
anderen zu helfen
danke ihnen für ihren einsatz
wir konnten zirka 50.000 leute mit 3,2
millionen liter trinkwasser versorgen
wie sind sie eigentlich von der
bevölkerung aufgenommen worden
wir wurden sehr herzlich aufgenommen von
der bevölkerung sie waren unendlich
dankbar für unsere hilfe